OK, Lorraine, 17 years old. Wants to be a dentist, which I didn't even know that was a thing anybody wants in high school, but shows what I know. Apparently, there are armies of teenagers who want to put on a white coat and enlist in the international war between human beings and placque.
好的，Lorraine，17岁。她想成为一名牙医，我甚至都不知道高中生会想做这个，但这说明我还不够了解情况。显然，有成群结队的青少年想穿上白大褂，投身于人类与牙菌斑之间的国际战争中。
I was in Saturday Academy, which is NYU's dentistry program for high schoolers. It was virtual.
我参加了周六学院，这是纽约大学为高中生开设的牙科项目。它是线上进行的。
What was the best thing about that? What did they do? What was your favorite part of it?
那次经历最棒的是什么？他们做了些什么？你最喜欢其中的哪个部分？
My favorite part was filling cavities. They sent a fake tooth model thing. Like, decay on the teeth, you had to scrape it off. It was like I was an actual dentist. They sent the tools. It was fun. It was so much fun.
我最喜欢的部分是补牙洞。他们寄来了一个假牙模型之类的东西。牙齿上有蛀牙，你得把它刮掉。那种感觉就像我真的是一名牙医一样。他们寄来了工具。那很有趣。真是太有趣了。
So last spring, junior year, Lorraine started to get serious with her college applications. She's a good student, great GPA. But she had a problem. Her dream colleges-- Cornell, Columbia, NYU-- they all wanted SAT scores 200 or 300 points higher than Lorraine's SAT scores. But then, Lorraine got this crazy break. All over the country, SATs were being canceled because of coronavirus. There was no safe way to fill a room with high school kids to take the test. And colleges started to change their admissions requirements.
所以去年春天，也就是高二升高三的时候，Lorraine开始认真对待她的大学申请了。她是个好学生，绩点也很高。但她遇到了一个问题。她梦寐以求的大学——康奈尔大学、哥伦比亚大学、纽约大学——要求的SAT成绩都比Lorraine的成绩高出200到300分。但随后，Lorraine迎来了一个疯狂的转机。因为新冠疫情，全国各地的SAT考试都被取消了。没有一种安全的方法可以让高中生聚集在教室里参加考试。于是，各大学开始改变他们的招生要求。
So I heard that a lot of schools were going test optional. Especially on TikTok, that's where I would see everything-- college updates, test optional updates.
所以我听说很多学校都实行了“可选考试”政策。特别是在TikTok上，我在那里能看到一切消息——大学更新、可选考试的更新。
Test optional means the SAT test is optional. You can apply without submitting SAT scores-- or ACT scores for that matter. If Lorraine's dream schools were to go test optional, it would magically vaporize the only obstacle standing between her and them and a life drilling into the molars of her fellow citizens. But most of the early schools to go test optional seemed to be out west, she said. All three of her top picks were in New York. Every day she would go online to check the lists of test optional schools.
“可选考试”意味着SAT考试不再是强制性的。你可以不提交SAT成绩——或者ACT成绩——进行申请。如果Lorraine梦寐以求的学校实行了可选考试政策，那就等于凭空抹去了横亘在她与梦想之间、以及她未来为同胞钻牙齿的事业之间的唯一障碍。但她说，当时大多数实行可选考试政策的学校似乎都在西部。她心目中的三所首选学校都在纽约。她每天都会上网查看可选考试学校的名单。
And I would keep refreshing, keep looking to see every single day, see if any new schools were added.
我每天都会不停地刷新、不停地查看，看看是否有新学校加入。
And were they changing every day?
它们每天都在变吗？
Yeah, I feel like two, three schools were added every single day.
是的，我觉得每天都会增加两三所学校。
And then I remember it was spring break because I dedicated my whole spring break to studying for SATs. And then I remember I got the notification, a little bell from Gmail from Columbia University because I signed up for their mailing list. And it was like, oh, yeah, we're going test optional. And I was studying. I had the SAT book open. So I threw it across my bed. My mom was the first person I told. So I ran to her. I was like, [SPANISH]-- like, I don't have to take the SATs, and stuff. I gave her a hug. We jumped. And then I called my friend, and I started screaming on the phone. We started dancing.
我记得那是春假，因为我把整个春假都用来准备SAT考试了。我记得我收到了通知，那是哥伦比亚大学发来的Gmail提醒，因为我注册了他们的邮件列表。上面写着，哦，是的，我们实行可选考试了。当时我正在学习。我翻开了SAT书。所以我把它扔到了床上。我妈妈是我第一个告诉的人。所以我跑去告诉她。我说，[西班牙语]——就是说，我不用参加SAT考试了之类的。我拥抱了她。我们跳了起来。然后我给朋友打了电话，我在电话里尖叫起来。我们开始跳舞。
Oh my god. It's like you got hit by lightning or something, but in a good way.
天哪。这感觉就像你被闪电击中了一样，但却是件好事。
Yeah. I thought that maybe now without the SAT, I kind of have a chance. I have a shot. Like, shoot for the stars. This is my year.
是的。我心想也许现在没有了SAT，我就有机会了。我有希望了。就像，向星空进发吧。这是属于我的一年。
She had been planning to apply to 10 or 11 colleges. Now she upped the number to 17. And all across the country, there were lots of kids doing that. But the pandemic has upended college admissions in so many ways that a huge swath of the country's high school seniors are having the opposite experience from Lorraine's. They're not applying to schools, falling through the cracks, ghosting their counselors who can't just grab them in the hallway or pull them from class this year. Having tried everything else in response, a few weeks ago in Fort Worth, Texas, high school counselor Valerie Gonzalez and a couple of the counselors she supervises hit the streets with a list of students' addresses to try to catch them at their homes.
她原本计划申请10到11所大学。现在她把数字增加到了17所。全国各地有很多孩子都在这样做。但疫情在许多方面颠覆了大学招生，以至于全国相当大一部分高中应届毕业生正经历着与Lorraine截然相反的境遇。他们没有申请学校，被遗漏了，也联系不上他们的辅导员——辅导员今年无法在走廊里拦住他们或把他们从课堂里叫出来。为了应对这种情况，几周前在德克萨斯州沃思堡，高中辅导员Valerie Gonzalez和她指导的几位辅导员拿着学生的住址名单走上街头，试图在他们家里找到他们。
We're pretty nervous, too, because we've never done anything like this before. So we'll see.
我们也挺紧张的，因为我们以前从未做过这样的事。所以，走着瞧吧。
Valerie's 25, the first in her family to go to a four-year college, placed as a counselor in this high school by a nonprofit called College Advising Corps to encourage kids to be the first in their families. And she's pretty hardcore about it.
Valerie今年25岁，是家里第一个上四年制大学的人。她被“大学咨询团”（College Advising Corps）这个非营利组织分配到这所高中担任辅导员，旨在鼓励孩子们成为家族中第一代大学生。她对此非常执着。
Yeah, I've actually definitely cried with students before when I've kind of told them, why are you doing this to yourself? You have an opportunity, especially even just to go to community college. Please do something to better your life.
是的，我其实真的曾经和学生一起哭过，当我在问他们，为什么你要这样对待自己？你有一个机会，哪怕只是去社区学院。请做点什么来改善你的生活吧。
She throws herself into a job with such energetic thoroughness that before going door to door this morning, she made little goodie bags to give out with face masks and stickers that she made by hand. She and another counselor check an address and walk up to a door.
她以一种精力充沛、彻彻底底的态度投入工作，以至于今天早上挨家挨户拜访之前，她还亲手制作了装有口罩和贴纸的小礼品袋。她和另一位辅导员核对了一个地址，然后走到门口。
[KNOCKING]
[敲门声]
[DOGS BARKING]
[狗叫声]
Well, there's doggies. Hi.
哦，有狗狗。你好。
Hello.
你好。
So we're from the Go Center. I'm Ms. Gonzalez. And basically, we are just coming around. We wanted to give you this and invite you to our event. And basically, do you need any help applying to college or anything? Or do you know what you want to do after you graduate?
我们来自Go中心。我是Gonzalez老师。基本上，我们只是四处走访。我们想给你这个，并邀请你参加我们的活动。基本上，你在申请大学或其它方面需要任何帮助吗？或者你知道你毕业后想做什么吗？
I might take a year off.
我可能会休学一年。
You might take a year off?
你可能会休学一年？
Yes.
是的。
Might take a year off is not the answer Valerie's looking for, but she's gotten a lot of it since the pandemic. At the high school she's at, Western Hills, the senior class last year, at this point in the year, 70% of them had applied to colleges in Texas. This year's senior class? Just 45%.
“可能会休学一年”不是Valerie想要的答案，但自从疫情以来，她听到了很多这样的回答。在她所在的高中——西山高中（Western Hills），去年的高三学生，在每年的这个时候，70%的人已经申请了德克萨斯州的大学。而今年的高三学生呢？只有45%。
Yeah. Many of my kids either don't want to go to college because they're already working.
是的。我的很多孩子要么不想上大学，因为他们已经在工作了。
Working to help their families during the pandemic.
为了在疫情期间补贴家用而工作。
Or they just want to go to community college. And you're like, well, why? You have a 3.8 GPA. You could go to a lot of four-year universities on scholarship. Why are you setting your sights low? And most of them are like, well, I want to stay close to home, or my mom is really concerned about COVID, and she doesn't want me to go anywhere. And the other thing, too, is the cost. Some of my students are like, why am I going to go to college? Why am I going to pay $50,000 if my classes are going to be virtual, and I'm not even going to get to go to class with my professors? It's going to all going to be online.
或者他们只想去社区学院。你会说，好吧，为什么？你的绩点是3.8。你可以通过奖学金进入很多四年制大学。为什么你的目标定得这么低？他们大多数人会说，嗯，我想待在离家近的地方，或者我妈妈非常担心新冠疫情，她不想让我去任何地方。另一个原因就是费用。我的一些学生会说，我为什么要上大学？如果我的课程都要在线上进行，而且我甚至不能和教授一起去上课，我为什么要付5万美元？一切都将在网上进行。
Let me take you on one last stop on this mini college tour. In the scrambled year, colleges are seeing things they've never seen before. Lots of schools are not getting anywhere near the number of applications that they're used to, especially less selective schools because of students like Valerie's. Some schools are down 15%, 20%, and looking to take massive financial hits because of it.
让我带你参加这次迷你大学巡回展的最后一站。在这一混乱的年份里，大学看到了他们从未见过的情况。许多学校收到的申请数量远不及往常，尤其是那些录取要求较低的学校，因为像Valerie学生那样的学生流失了。一些学校申请量下降了15%、20%，并因此面临巨大的财务冲击。
Meanwhile, schools you might think of as having brand recognition and big flagship state schools, they're seeing a surge in applications. Lorraine's first choice schools, for example, NYU applications were up 20%, Cornell's up 31%, Columbia is up 51%, driven probably by students like Lorraine, who were hoping that this is their year, with no SATs blocking the way.
与此同时，那些你认为拥有品牌知名度和大型旗舰州立大学的学校，申请量却出现了激增。例如，Lorraine的首选学校，纽约大学的申请量增长了20%，康奈尔大学增长了31%，哥伦比亚大学增长了51%，这大概是由像Lorraine这样的学生推动的，他们希望今年是属于他们的一年，没有SAT成绩的阻碍。
But even schools with great numbers aren't feeling great. Jon Boeckenstedt runs undergrad admissions for Oregon State, which has 34% more applications this year than last. He also writes about higher education and talks to admissions officers around the country.
但即使是数据非常漂亮的学校感觉也不太好。Jon Boeckenstedt负责俄勒冈州立大学的本科招生，该校今年的申请量比去年增加了34%。他还撰写关于高等教育的文章，并与全国各地的招生官员交谈。
Yeah, we're all sort of confused and befuddled. And a few of us are frankly terrified by what these numbers mean.
是的，我们大家都有些困惑和迷茫。而且坦率地说，我们中的一些人被这些数字意味着什么吓坏了。
Terrified because usually when they say yes to a bunch of applicants, they can predict how many of them are going to actually choose to enroll at their school. But this year, the normal indicators they would use for that are gone. For instance, did the student make a campus visit, which means they would be more likely to enroll in the fall. Well, those didn't happen this year. Or they had a high SAT score. Normally that would mean more schools want those students, and they would be less likely to enroll at Oregon State. But of course, they don't have the SAT scores. And so, as a result, when Boeckenstedt offers a place in his first year class to thousands of kids--
之所以感到害怕，是因为通常当他们录取一批申请者时，他们可以预测其中有多少人实际上会选择入学。但今年，他们通常使用的指标已经消失了。例如，学生是否进行过校园参观，这意味着他们更有可能在秋季入学。好吧，今年这些都没发生。或者他们有很高的SAT分数。通常这意味着更多的学校想要这些学生，他们入学俄勒冈州立大学的可能性就会降低。但当然，他们没有SAT分数。因此，当Boeckenstedt为成千上万的孩子提供一年级入学名额时——
We might have way too many students enroll in the fall. And then the residence halls are crowded, and we don't have sufficient classroom space. And we just don't know how to handle the crush. On the other hand, too few students enroll, which is, again, scary. We're used to thinking of application increases as good things. And this year, we just don't know what they mean.
我们秋季入学的人数可能会多得离谱。那样宿舍会很拥挤，我们也没有足够的教室空间。我们简直不知道如何应对这种爆满。另一方面，如果入学的学生太少，这同样很可怕。我们习惯于认为申请量增加是好事。但今年，我们根本不知道这意味着什么。
For today on our program, college admissions in this pandemic year. So much is different this year. So much is unknown. And today on our program, we've chosen to focus on one very specific part of the picture, one of the most interesting things that got thrown into the air this year. And that is the SATs. For years, there have been people saying that they're unfair. Schools should not require them. And now, finally, like this vast national science experiment, most colleges have stopped requiring them. What's that look like? Will it actually change who gets into more selective schools? Have we crossed some line and we're not going back? From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
今天的节目主题是：疫情这一年的大学招生。今年太多事情不同了。太多事情是未知的。在今天的节目中，我们选择关注整个情况中一个非常具体的方面，一个今年最有趣的被抛向空中的变量。那就是SAT考试。多年来，一直有人说它们是不公平的。学校不应该要求它们。现在，终于，就像一场巨大的国家科学实验，大多数大学已经不再要求SAT了。那会是什么样子？它真的会改变谁能进入更具选择性的学校吗？我们是否越过了某种界限，从此一去不回了？来自WBEZ芝加哥电台，这里是《This American Life》。我是Ira Glass。请继续收听。
So for months now, I've been looking into what's happening with college admissions since the pandemic with reporter Paul Tough, who's been on our show many times, who writes about education. And in fact, his most recent book is on the admissions process and the students that that system is not working for. Hey there, Paul.
几个月来，我一直在和撰写教育问题的记者Paul Tough一起调查疫情以来大学招生的情况，他多次做客我们的节目。事实上，他最近的一本书就是关于招生过程以及那个体系未能覆盖的学生。你好，Paul。
Hey, Ira.
你好，Ira。
So, Paul, one of the things you point out in your book is that this period when kids apply to college is this unusual moment, probably the biggest moment in kids' lives in this country, when they get a real chance at social mobility.
Paul，你在书中指出的事情之一是，孩子们申请大学的这段时期是一个不同寻常的时刻，这可能是这个国家孩子们一生中最重要的时刻，因为他们获得了真正的社会流动机会。
Yeah, going to college pays off in all kinds of ways. You're more likely to make more money, more likely to get married, more likely to live longer, to say you're happy. But it also makes a big difference where you go to college. This Harvard economist, Raj Chetty, did a study, and he found that for students who go to the most selective schools, the Ivy League schools and schools like it, have a one in five chance of making it into the top 1% of earners as an adult. If you go to a slightly less selective school, you have a one in 11 chance of making it into the top 1%. Go to community college, it's a one in 300 chance. Don't go to college at all, a one in 1,000 chance. So this moment in high school when kids are sorted into more and less selective institutions, it matters a lot.
是的，上大学在各个方面都有回报。你赚更多钱的可能性更大，结婚的可能性更大，寿命更长的可能性更大，说自己幸福的可能性也更大。但你上哪所大学也有很大影响。这位哈佛经济学家Raj Chetty做了一项研究，他发现对于那些进入最具选择性学校——常春藤盟校及类似学校——的学生来说，他们有五分之一的机会在成年后进入收入前1%。如果你进入一所选择性略低的学校，你有十一分之一的机会进入前1%。去社区学院，机会是三百分之一。根本不上大学，机会是一千分之一。所以，当孩子们被分流到更具选择性和选择性较低的机构时，高中阶段的这一刻非常重要。
And that brings us to the subject of our show today, the SATs. They have been a big part of this sorting for a long time. And for the last few decades, there's been this debate about whether colleges should require the SATs. And one school after another has decided not to, has gone test optional. Notably, in 2018, the University of Chicago, one of the most rigorous and selective schools in the country, did it. And last spring, the biggest public system in the country, the University of California with over 225,000 undergrads on nine campuses, did away with the SAT.
这就带到了我们今天节目的主题，SAT考试。长期以来，它们一直是这种分流的重要组成部分。在过去几十年里，关于大学是否应该要求SAT一直存在争议。一所接一所的学校决定不再要求它，实行了可选考试。值得注意的是，2018年，芝加哥大学——全国最严苛和最具选择性的学校之一——做到了这一点。去年春天，全国最大的公共教育系统，拥有超过225,000名本科生、分布在九个校区的加州大学，也废除了SAT。
At the time that the pandemic hit, about half of the country's four-year colleges were test optional. But still, the overwhelming majority of the country's most selective schools, including the Ivy League, were not test optional. They still required the SAT. And there was a real question-- should they do it? And then, with the pandemic, they did. Another 600 schools suddenly did not require the SAT, including pretty much all the most selective schools.
疫情袭来时，大约一半的四年制大学实行了可选考试。但仍然，该国绝大多数最具选择性的学校，包括常春藤盟校，并未实行可选考试。他们仍然要求SAT。当时有一个真正的问题——他们应该这样做吗？然后，随着疫情爆发，他们做到了。又有600所学校突然不再要求SAT，包括几乎所有最具选择性的学校。
And we're going to look in today's show at what that has meant, especially for the kind of students who have been kept from those schools by the SAT in the past. And we're going to look at what's likely to happen with the SAT after the pandemic. But just to start here at the beginning, we should explain for anybody who hasn't followed this why schools were questioning the SAT in the first place. And Paul, you're going to take this part of the story. I'll see you again in a couple of minutes.
在今天的节目中，我们将看看这意味着什么，特别是对于那些过去一直被SAT阻挡在这些学校之外的学生。我们将看看疫情后SAT可能会发生什么。但首先，我们要从头开始，为那些没关注过这个问题的人解释为什么学校最初要质疑SAT。Paul，这部分故事由你来讲述。几分钟后再见。
If you want to understand why people are questioning the SAT these days, you should meet Daniela. She's one of those kids who seems destined for college. Her family immigrated to Riverside, California from Mexico when she was eight. She started third grade there, not speaking a word of English. And by the time she got to high school, she was taking honors classes, getting amazing grades, even though she was also working 20 hours a week cleaning houses and standing on street corners, flipping signs. There was a group of five students at the top of the class, and Daniela was always up there in that group. For most of high school, in fact, she was number one.
如果你想了解为什么人们现在质疑SAT，你应该见见Daniela。她就是那种注定要上大学的孩子。她八岁时随家人从墨西哥移民到加利福尼亚州河滨市。她在那里上三年级时，连一句英语都不会说。到了高中，她开始修荣誉课程，成绩优异，尽管她同时还在做兼职，一周工作20小时——打扫房屋，在街角翻动广告牌。班里前五名有一组学生，Daniela一直名列其中。事实上，在高中大部分时间里，她是第一名。
The only B I ever got in class was my senior year in my Spanish class. I didn't really care too much about it, just because I already knew Spanish. So it wasn't my focus.
我在课堂上唯一拿到过的一次B是在高三的西班牙语课上。我对此并不太在意，只是因为我已经懂西班牙语了。所以它不是我的重点。
I can't believe it's Spanish where you got your B.
真不敢相信你竟然是在西班牙语课上拿到那个B的。
I know.
我知道。
I'm guessing you're pretty good at Spanish.
我猜你的西班牙语应该很不错。
I was really good at it, but I never showed up. But at the end of the day, the participation was what killed me. I was destroyed. I cried. I was like, no, my only B.
我真的很擅长，但我从没去上过课。但归根结底，课堂参与度毁了我。我崩溃了。我哭了。我说，不，那是我的唯一一个B。
She wanted to go to an Ivy League college or one of the elite University of California schools, like Berkeley or UCLA, and be a doctor. And then she took the SAT.
她想进入常春藤盟校或加州大学的精英分校之一，比如伯克利分校或洛杉矶分校，成为一名医生。然后她参加了SAT考试。
No, yeah, definitely the SAT was kind of humbling. I was like, all these years, I grew up thinking I was kind of a genius because everybody was telling me. And then the SAT was like, no, you're not.
不，是的，毫无疑问，SAT确实让我谦卑了一些。我想，这些年来，我成长过程中一直以为自己是个天才，因为每个人都这么告诉我。然后SAT就说，不，你不是。
This was during the years when the SAT wasn't using the 1,600-point scale that most people would know. But if you translated her score to today's scores, it would be about 1,180. That's a fine score, better than about 70% of the students who take the test. But it's not the kind of score that straight-A students usually get. And it isn't the kind of score that will get you into Ivy League schools or Berkeley or UCLA.
这是在SAT还没有使用大多数人所熟知的1600分制的那几年。但如果你把她的分数换算成今天的标准，大约是1180分。这是一个不错的分数，比大约70%参加考试的学生要好。但这并不是全A学生通常能拿到的分数。而且这也不是能让你进入常春藤盟校、伯克利或洛杉矶分校的分数。
The five students at the top of Daniela's class were all super smart and ambitious. They competed with each other usually in a friendly way. She was number one until that one B, and then she slipped to number three. But when it came time for the SAT, Daniela noticed that three of those five, the ones who had more money, the ones whose parents were doctors, their families invested in the SAT. One kid's family paid for an expensive online course. One family hired a private tutor. Those students got top SAT scores. Only one of the five, a boy, got a score like hers.
Daniela班上前五名的学生都非常聪明且有抱负。他们通常以友好的方式相互竞争。她在拿到那个B之前一直是第一名，之后滑落到了第三名。但在SAT考试来临时，Daniela注意到这五个人中的三个人——那些更有钱的、父母是医生的——他们的家庭在SAT上进行了投资。一个孩子的家庭支付了昂贵的在线课程费用。一个家庭聘请了私人导师。那些学生拿到了顶尖的SAT分数。五人中只有一个男生拿到了和她差不多的分数。
He did around the same score as me. And I saw him to be smarter than a lot of these people, but he came from a lower class family, a family that came from poverty as well. All the students that I saw do well came from money.
他的分数和我差不多。我认为他比很多人都聪明，但他来自低收入家庭，一个同样来自贫困背景的家庭。我看到所有表现出色的学生都来自有钱人家。
Daniela wasn't the first person to notice this relationship between family income and test scores. It's been documented for years. Better off kids do better on the SAT for all kinds of reasons. Not just the private tutors and the 600-page study guides, they're also more likely to live in better neighborhoods, so they go to better schools. All of the advantages that go along with growing up with money feed into that test score. Still, for Daniela, it was frustrating.
Daniela并不是第一个注意到家庭收入与考试成绩之间这种关系的人。多年来，这已被记录在案。富裕家庭的孩子SAT考得更好，原因有很多。不仅仅是私人导师和600页的学习指南，他们还更有可能生活在更好的社区，因此他们去更好的学校。所有伴随金钱成长带来的优势都助长了考试分数。尽管如此，对Daniela来说，这令人沮丧。
I'm also wondering, was there a way that that experience of getting the score that you did, did it sort of change your feeling about yourself as a student?
我还想知道，拿到那个分数的经历是否在某种程度上改变了你对自己作为学生的看法？
Definitely. I think it was disheartening just because it was kind of like where I first questioned whether I was at their same level type of thing. Yeah, it definitely made me question a lot of my qualities or skills or-- yeah.
当然。我想这很令人沮丧，因为这就像是我第一次质疑自己是否和他们处于同一水平。是的，它确实让我质疑了很多自己的素质、技能或者……是的。
Did you feel like you were as smart as them?
你觉得你和他们一样聪明吗？
I did. I felt like in class, I performed just as well as them. But that test was saying otherwise, you know? So when I got that test result, I was kind of questioning whether I was.
我觉得。我觉得在课堂上，我的表现和他们一样好。但那个测试却说情况并非如此，你知道吗？所以当我拿到那个测试结果时，我开始怀疑自己是否真的聪明。
That's so interesting. It sounds like there's a side of you that was like, oh, no, I'm definitely as smart as them. But there was maybe another side of you that was like, well, wait, maybe this is the real measure of who's smart and who's not. Was your brain sort of going back and forth between those two ideas?
这太有趣了。听起来你有一面是这样想的：哦不，我绝对和他们一样聪明。但也许还有另一面是：好吧，等等，也许这就是衡量谁聪明谁不聪明的真正标准。你的大脑是在这两种想法之间摇摆吗？
Yes, definitely. That's exactly what was happening. One side was like, no, I've seen these people, how they've analyzed an essay. I've seen how they've solved that problem. I know that I wrote out this research paper better than them, you know? I have seen them perform, and I have seen how my skills compare to them. And then but at the same time, I would think maybe this test is actually testing who's smarter. And this whole time I've been like passing by on a fluke or on luck.
是的，绝对是。发生的情况正是这样。一面是，不，我已经见过这些人，见过他们是如何分析文章的。我见过他们是如何解决那个问题的。我知道我写出的那篇研究论文比他们好，你知道吗？我见过他们的表现，也见过我的技能是如何与他们相提并论的。但与此同时，我会想，也许这个测试确实在测试谁更聪明。而我一直以来只是靠侥幸或运气过关。
Do you think there was something about like the way that the test was presented that made it seem like, well, maybe this is the real measure of who's smart and who's not?
你认为测试呈现的方式是否让你觉得，好吧，也许这才是衡量谁聪明谁不聪明的真正标准？
Yeah, just the fact that this is what all these institutions are basing off entrance. If you do good, you deserve to go to college. If you don't, then it's not. So then I'm here questioning, should I even go to college? Am I even built for college? I don't even know if I'll do good in college because I clearly can't do good in this test. So yeah, it's presented like, if you don't do well, you're not going to do well in college.
是的，仅仅因为这是所有这些机构进行入学的依据。如果你做得好，你就值得上大学。如果你做得不好，就不行。所以我在这里质疑，我甚至应该上大学吗？我真的适合上大学吗？我甚至不知道我在大学里表现如何，因为我显然在这个测试中表现不好。所以是的，它的呈现方式好像是：如果你表现不好，你在大学里也不会表现好。
It's not surprising that Daniela had that thought. For years, that's how the SAT was sold-- as an objective measure of intelligence, a scientific indicator of who would succeed in college, more accurate than the grades that kids get in high school.
Daniela有这种想法并不奇怪。多年来，SAT就是这样被推销的——作为一种客观的智力衡量标准，一种科学的指标，能说明谁会在大学里成功，比孩子们在高中拿到的成绩更准确。
There's a lot of research, though, including studies from the College Board, the nonprofit organization that administers the SAT, that shows that this isn't quite true. Let me tell you the stuff that researchers mostly agree on. First, that high school grades are slightly better than SAT scores at predicting how well students will do in their first year in college, whether they'll graduate on time. If you can only have one number to judge a student, high school grades are your best bet.
不过，包括SAT管理机构非营利组织“大学理事会”（College Board）的研究在内，有很多研究表明这并不完全属实。让我告诉你研究人员基本达成共识的事情。首先，高中成绩在预测学生大学一年级表现——以及他们是否能按时毕业——方面，稍微比SAT成绩更好。如果你只能有一个数字来评判学生，高中成绩是你最好的选择。
Second, that if you look at the combination of a student's high school GPA and their SAT score, then you can predict their college performance slightly better than you can with just their high school grades alone. What they don't agree on is whether that extra bit of predictive power you get with the SAT is worth the cost. Because there's a third thing that everyone agrees on, and that is that SAT and ACT scores heavily favor rich kids, much more so than high school grades.
其次，如果你结合学生的GPA和SAT成绩来看，你可以比仅看GPA稍微更好地预测他们的大学表现。他们不认同的是，你从SAT获得的额外预测能力是否值得其代价。因为所有人还同意第三点，那就是SAT和ACT成绩严重偏向富家子弟，比高中成绩偏向得多。
So if you use standardized tests in admissions, you're probably going to reject a lot of perfectly good students, who could succeed at your institution. And the students you're rejecting are more likely to be low income and first generation and non-white. The SAT is like a doctor's test that gives you a lot of false negatives. And students who are already underrepresented on campuses are more likely to be kept out of college by one of those false negatives.
所以如果你在招生中使用标准化考试，你可能会拒绝许多完全有资格在你所在机构取得成功的优秀学生。而你拒绝的那些学生更有可能是低收入群体、第一代大学生和非白人学生。SAT就像一个医生测试，会给出大量的“假阴性”结果。而校园里本已代表性不足的学生，更有可能因为这些假阴性结果而被挡在大学门外。
In Daniela's case, when she saw her score, she decided it would be hopeless to apply to all her first choice schools-- Harvard, the other Ivy's, Berkeley. She applied to computer science at UCLA, whose average SAT was 300 points higher than hers, and didn't get in. As for the three affluent students in the top five, the ones with the SAT tutors and courses, they were accepted to Berkeley, Penn, and Harvard. The boy who came from the same background as Daniela went to Riverside Community College. And Daniela wound up at the University of California at Merced, the newest and least selective UC school. And Daniela says that seems like what the SAT is intended to do.
在Daniela的案例中，当她看到自己的分数时，她认为申请她心目中的首选学校——哈佛、其他常春藤盟校、伯克利——是无望的。她申请了加州大学洛杉矶分校（UCLA）的计算机科学专业，该校的SAT平均分比她高出300分，结果没被录取。至于前五名中那三位富裕的学生，那些有SAT导师和课程的学生，他们被伯克利、宾大和哈佛录取了。那个和Daniela背景相同的男生去了里弗赛德社区学院。而Daniela最终去了加州大学默塞德分校，这是加州大学体系中最新、选择性最低的分校。Daniela说，这似乎就是SAT的目的。
It's meant to weed out-- it's mean to gatekeep, in my opinion.
在我看来，它旨在淘汰……它旨在把门设障。
And do you think of it as like, it's just sort of accidentally keeping people out, or you feel like it's designed to keep people like you out of those colleges?
你认为这只是某种意外地把人挡在门外，还是你觉得它就是设计用来把像你这样的人挡在那些大学门外的？
I don't think it's accidental because I think that by now, the test has been around long enough to whether they could see patterns. So I feel like maybe at first, it was accidental. But now if they are seeing consistent patterns of students with certain socioeconomic backgrounds or ethnic backgrounds are doing not as good as others, then it has to be intentional.
我不认为这是意外，因为我认为到目前为止，这个测试存在的时间已经足够长，可以观察到规律。所以我感觉也许起初是意外的。但现在，如果他们能看到某些社会经济背景或种族背景的学生成绩持续不如其他人，那么这一定是故意的。
The people who run the SAT and the ACT, they would definitely say that it's not intentional, that certain groups do poorly on standardized tests because they face other disadvantages that hold back their academic progress. But it's certainly true that for decades now, these tests have kept excellent students like Daniela out of the best schools. Until just maybe this year-- when the majority of colleges, for the very first time, went test optional. The question is, did that help? Are students like Daniela now going to actually get into these more selective schools? The answer is complicated. And Ira's going to pick up this part of the story.
运营SAT和ACT的人，他们肯定会说这不是故意的，某些群体在标准化考试中表现不佳是因为他们面临其他不利因素，阻碍了他们的学业进步。但不可否认的是，几十年来，这些测试确实把像Daniela这样的优秀学生挡在了最好的学校门外。直到可能就是今年——当大多数大学第一次实行了可选考试。问题是，这有帮助吗？像Daniela这样的学生现在真的能进入这些更具选择性的学校吗？答案很复杂。Ira将继续讲述这部分故事。
Thanks, Paul. OK, so what's going to happen to students like Daniela without the SAT blocking them from top schools? Well, to give you a sense of that, let's look at one of those selective name brand schools that saw an increase in applications this year, thanks to test optional. Georgia Tech until this year used the SATs as one of the things that it looked at in screening applicants.
谢谢，Paul。好了，没有了SAT阻挡，像Daniela这样的学生会发生什么？好吧，为了让你有所了解，让我们看看那些今年因为“可选考试”而申请量增加的品牌名校之一。佐治亚理工学院在今年之前，一直把SAT作为考察申请者的一项内容。
Then they went test optional because of the pandemic and got 11% more applications, and they got a more diverse application pool. Black students up 20%, students whose parents who didn't go to college, first generation students, up 20%. This, by the way, is typical even in non-pandemic times. When a school goes test optional, more kids think, hmm, maybe I can get in, and they apply. And the diversity of the applicants also increases.
然后因为疫情，他们实行了可选考试，申请量增加了11%，而且他们获得了更多样化的申请群体。黑人学生增加了20%，父母没上过大学的学生（第一代大学生）增加了20%。顺便说一下，即使在非疫情时期，这也是典型的。当学校实行可选考试时，更多的孩子会想，嗯，也许我能进去，于是他们就申请了。申请者的多样性也会增加。
The big questions next, of course, are, number one, would Georgia Tech offer those new applicant spots for the fall? And number two, will they accept? Now question number one, we actually now know the answer. They have sent out their offers to students. They did it about a week ago. Rick Clark, the head of undergrad admissions, says they have admitted 28% more Black students than last year, 20% more first generation students.
接下来的大问题当然是，第一，佐治亚理工学院是否会给这些新申请者提供名额？第二，他们会接受吗？现在第一个问题，我们实际上已经知道答案了。他们已经向学生发出了录取通知。大约在一周前。本科招生负责人Rick Clark说，他们录取的黑人学生比去年多了28%，第一代大学生多了20%。
And I'm pleased with that. I mean, we have a relatively new president, expanding access is a key part of his strategic plan.
对此我感到很高兴。我的意思是，我们有一位相对较新的校长，扩大受教育机会是他战略计划的关键部分。
Wait, so that was set as a goal in the fall?
等等，所以那是在秋季设定的目标？
Yes.
是的。
And now so here you are with these numbers. So, things are going great, right? That's great.
现在你拿到了这些数字。所以，事情进展得很顺利，对吧？那太棒了。
That's great, yes. I know. We're very, very pleased. And now of course we're turning our attention to, all right, we have to convince these students to choose us.
是的，太棒了。我知道。我们非常、非常高兴。当然，现在我们的注意力转向了，好吧，我们必须说服这些学生选择我们。
And that's where things get hard because of money. Georgia Tech has a limited amount of financial aid to give out. On average, students only get half of what they need.
而这正是困难的地方，因为钱。佐治亚理工学院能提供的财务援助是有限的。平均而言，学生只能得到他们所需的一半。
Georgia Tech does not meet or commit to meeting that high percentage of need. Georgia Tech doesn't do that. We basically say, here is what it's going to cost to come to Georgia Tech. If you are able to finance that education, then you can obviously accept our offer. Whether or not they can make that kind of financial commitment, and often, in the end, have to take loans to do it, is going to be up to the family. So we make those offers, understanding that we probably aren't going to be able to yield them all.
佐治亚理工学院并没有也不承诺满足那部分高需求。佐治亚理工学院不做那个。我们基本上说，来佐治亚理工学院要花这么多钱。如果你有能力负担这笔教育费用，那么你显然可以接受我们的录取。他们是否能做出那样的财务承诺，而且最终往往不得不为此贷款，将取决于家庭。所以我们发出录取通知时，很清楚我们可能无法吸引他们所有人入学。
Aren't going to be able to yield is admissions speak for they know the students aren't all going to enroll.
“无法吸引他们入学”是招生术语，意指他们知道并非所有学生都会选择入读。
We know that from the very beginning.
我们从一开始就知道这一点。
Even somebody getting state scholarships and Federal Pell grants could end up still needing $10,000 a year for tuition, Clark says. And facing that, some students choose a school that offers more financial aid. But what's probably way more common everywhere this happens, they end up somewhere less selective, less prestigious, close to home, and cheaper, which is to say, it's not just the SATs that keep otherwise qualified, low income, and first generation students out of elite schools. It's also money-- specifically how much money colleges have to help those students. Until last year, Angel Perez was in charge of enrollment at Trinity College, where he saw this with every class he admitted.
即使是获得州奖学金和联邦佩尔助学金的人，最终可能仍需要每年1万美元的学费，Clark说。面对这种情况，一些学生选择了提供更多资助的学校。但最常见的做法可能随处可见，他们最终去了离家近、更便宜、选择性较低、名气较小的学校。也就是说，不仅仅是SAT让本来合格的低收入和第一代学生无法进入精英学校。金钱也是原因——特别是大学有多少钱来帮助这些学生。去年之前，Angel Perez负责三一学院的招生工作，他在录取的每一届学生中都看到了这一点。
You know, there were so many low income first gen kids in my pool that I could admit-- extremely qualified-- but there were only certain amount of dollars that I had in order to fully fund them.
你知道，我的申请库里有那么多低收入的第一代孩子，我可以录取他们——资质极高——但我手头用来全额资助他们的资金只有那么多。
I'm going to be back Paul Tough now, who reported today's program with me. Because Paul, when you wrote your latest book, you actually followed Angel Perez during this process as he tried to enroll more low income and first generation kids at Trinity College.
我要请回和我一起报道今天节目的Paul Tough。因为Paul，当你写最新一本书时，你实际上跟踪了Angel Perez在这一过程中的工作，他试图在三一学院招收更多的低收入和第一代大学生。
Yeah, it was really hard. I mean, there was no question that this was what he wanted to do. This is what the president of the college wanted him to do. But at the same time, Trinity College was losing millions of dollars a year. And they are, like many institutions, a place that gets most of their revenue from tuition. He had a goal that he had to make to get a certain amount of tuition from all the students that he admitted. I think it was $19 million he needed to bring in. And so, it didn't mean that he only admitted rich kids who could pay a lot, but it did mean that every student that he was evaluating, that was the first question he had to ask. Is this someone who's going to help me with the bottom line or not?
是的，这真的很难。我的意思是，毫无疑问这是他想做的。这也是学院院长希望他做的。但与此同时，三一学院每年损失数百万美元。和许多机构一样，他们的大部分收入来自学费。他有一个目标，必须从他录取的所有学生身上获得一定数量的学费。我想是1900万美元。所以，这并不意味着他只录取那些付得起大钱的富家孩子，但这确实意味着他评估的每一名学生，那是他必须问的第一个问题。这个人是能帮我实现营收目标，还是不能？
Again, Angel Perez.
再次回到Angel Perez。
And every time you are thinking about adding a student or subtracting a student, you have to go back and run the econometric model to see financially where are you, and whether or not you have blown the financial aid budget or whether or not you now do not have enough predicted tuition revenue to uphold the college's budget the following year.
每次你考虑增加一名学生或减少一名学生时，你都必须回去运行计量经济模型，看看财务上你处于什么位置，以及你是否耗尽了财务援助预算，或者你是否没有足够的预测学费收入来维持学院来年的预算。
Paul, can you just talk about this thing that you saw him do that he had students that he really wanted to bring to Trinity that he just couldn't?
Paul，你能谈谈你看到的他做过的事情吗？他有一些他真的想带到三一学院的学生，但他就是没能带进来？
Yeah, I mean, it was especially at the last part of the process was when I saw it the most, right? Because he started off just creating the class that he really wanted, all these highly qualified students, including a lot more low income students, first generation students. But then it was right around this time of year. It was the middle of March.
是的，我的意思是，特别是在过程的最后阶段我看得最明显，对吧？因为他开始时只是在创建他真正想要的班级，所有这些高素质的学生，包括更多的低收入学生、第一代大学生。但随后就在每年的这个时候。那是三月中旬。
And everyone that he was admitting was making it harder for him to meet his tuition goals. Tensions were kind of running high. It was very emotional in his office with him and all of his admissions people. So the last weekend, he and the director of admissions just sent everybody else home, and they just sat together at their computer and went through one by one. And the last few dozen students that he cut were all low income ones who needed significant financial aid.
他录取的每一个人都让他更难实现学费目标。压力有点高。在他的办公室里，他和所有的招生人员都很情绪化。所以最后一个周末，他和招生主任打发走了其他人，他们独自坐在电脑前，逐一审阅。最后几十个被他剔除的学生全都是需要大量经济援助的低收入学生。
So that's a normal year. Think about how many of those low income students these same schools can afford today, Perez says, with the financial problems that schools have had since the pandemic. Perez actually monitors the big picture with admissions around the country today in the job that he took when he left Trinity College a year ago. He's now head of the National Association of College Admissions Counseling.
所以那是正常的一年。想想看， Perez说，在学校自疫情以来遇到的财务问题下，这些学校今天能负担得起多少低收入学生。 Perez在你一年前离开三一学院后担任的工作中，实际上正在监督全国各地的招生情况。他现在是全国大学招生咨询协会的负责人。
Even the wealthiest institutions with high endowments, they have taken big hits this year. And they collected less tuition. They are doing budget cuts. They are laying people off. And so, I'm hesitant to say we will see dramatic shifts in one year and underrepresented students at these institutions because of that difficult financial component.
即使是拥有高捐赠基金的最富有的机构，今年也遭受了重大打击。他们收取的学费减少了。他们正在进行预算削减。他们正在裁员。所以，由于那个困难的财务因素，我对于我们在这些机构看到代表性不足学生的巨大转变持保留态度。
He says he expects a small bump in the number of these students at certain kinds of schools like flagship state schools. But overall-- and this is important-- the number of low income students and first generation students going to college this coming fall is probably going to drop for the first time in years.
他说，他预计在旗舰州立大学等某些学校中，这些学生的数量会有小幅增加。但总的来说——这一点很重要——今年秋天进入大学的低收入学生和第一代大学生的数量可能会出现多年来的首次下降。
How do we know this? Well, a bunch of ways, but most significant, federal student aid applications, FAFSA, are down 10% this year overall. Lots of kids around the country are downgrading, delaying, or giving up on college plans because money has been so tight during the pandemic. I talked to one girl, Abigail, who took a job at Walmart's pharmacy to help her family, rather than go to community college. And now she was like, all right, she's making money. Why change?
我们怎么知道这一点？好吧，有很多种方法，但最显著的是，联邦学生援助申请（FAFSA）今年总体下降了10%。全国各地的许多孩子正在降级、延迟或放弃上大学的计划，因为疫情期间资金非常紧张。我和一个女孩Abigail谈过，她去沃尔玛的药房工作以帮助家人，而不是去社区学院。现在她想，好吧，她在挣钱。为什么要改变呢？
I do think about college a lot still. Maybe my life would be different, but I kind of like it how it is now. You kind of just realize that I like this lifestyle, and I don't really feel comfortable going with something I don't know like college. But if I like how I am right now and the money I'm making right now, then I shouldn't really go.
我仍然经常考虑上大学。也许我的生活会不同，但我挺喜欢现在的生活。你只是意识到我喜欢这种生活方式，我不觉得去尝试一些我不了解的东西，比如大学，很舒服。但如果我喜欢现在的自己和现在挣的钱，那么我就不应该去。
So this fall, expect some schools to see a small increase in students like Daniela, but the overall number of students like her going to college next year probably will drop.
所以今年秋天，预计一些学校看到像Daniela这样的学生人数会有小幅增加，但明年上大学的像她一样的学生总数可能会下降。
Calling around to admissions directors, one of the other things I was interested in was most of the best schools in the country were used to using the SAT as this tool to figure out who they were going to admit. For years, these schools have resisted calls to change that. So what was it like for them this year to do the jobs without it? The answer, of course, varied from school to school.
在给招生主任打电话时，我感兴趣的另一件事是，全国大多数最好的学校都习惯于使用SAT作为判断录取谁的工具。多年来，这些学校一直拒绝改变的呼声。那么今年在没有它的情况下工作对他们来说是什么感觉？答案当然因学校而异。
Jon Boeckenstedt, who runs admissions at Oregon State University, has watched and written about the politics of test optional for years. He likes test optional. In his career, he's taken two schools test optional. He says, this year, for many of his peers, he thinks it's a relief to have it gone. One of the ways that their schools were always judged was by their SAT scores, when the SAT scores are published each year in places like the US News and World Report Ranking of Best Colleges.
俄勒冈州立大学招生负责人Jon Boeckenstedt多年来一直关注并撰写关于可选考试政治的文章。他喜欢可选考试。在他的职业生涯中，他让两所学校实行了可选考试。他说，今年对他的许多同行来说，他认为没有它是一种解脱。他们的学校一直被评判的方式之一就是SAT分数，也就是每年在《美国新闻与世界报道》最佳大学排名等地方发布SAT分数的时候。
Yeah, I think if you talk to admissions people, they will say they're happy to be rid of the test. Because it allows them to make decisions free of that albatross hanging around their neck. They don't have to worry about the average test score going down. They can find students who are interesting and who would bring something really valuable to the campus, but may not have that stellar score.
是的，我想如果你和招生人员交谈，他们会说他们很高兴摆脱这个测试。因为它让他们能够在没有那个沉重枷锁的情况下做出决定。他们不必担心平均考试成绩下降。他们可以找到有趣、能为校园带来真正价值，但可能没有那种出众分数的学生。
In that sense, he says the pandemic let some admissions people get away with something they'd wanted to do for a while-- to ditch the SATs. Of course, lots of admissions directors did not see the SAT as an albatross. They saw it as valuable and helpful as they made their decisions. One person like that is the head of Undergraduate Admissions at Yale, Jeremiah Quinlan. He was lucid and unapologetic in listing the merits of the SAT in admissions at Yale. He says because they've got people applying from all kinds of schools all over the world--
从这个意义上说，他说疫情让一些招生人员能够实现他们一直想做的事情——抛弃SAT。当然，许多招生主任并不认为SAT是枷锁。他们认为这在做决定时很有价值和帮助。其中一个这样的人是耶鲁大学本科招生负责人Jeremiah Quinlan。他在列举SAT在耶鲁招生的优点时思路清晰且毫不掩饰。他说因为他们有来自世界各地各种学校的申请者——
It's useful to have something that's consistent among applicants, even when we're aware of how limited and imperfect that metric can be, AKA the SAT or the ACT. It could be especially valuable since our internal research-- we look at these things regularly-- show that the tests are predictive of Yale performance above and beyond high school GPA.
拥有在申请者之间保持一致的东西很有用，尽管我们意识到那个指标是多么有限和不完美，也就是SAT或ACT。它可以特别有价值，因为我们的内部研究——我们定期查看这些东西——表明这些测试在高中GPA之外，对耶鲁的表现有预测作用。
He means, in other words, even though studies show that in general, at most colleges, your high school GPA is a better predictor of how you do, with the particular population of students they have at Yale, he says, SAT predicts better how they do in their first year and over four years.
换句话说，即使研究表明，总体而言，在大多数大学，你的高中GPA是表现预测的更好指标，但他表示，对于耶鲁大学的学生群体，SAT能更好地预测他们第一年以及四年内的表现。
And it is often common that strong test scores helped boost the case of a student from an underrepresented background, who doesn't have other strong and compelling elements in their file, and elevate them in the committee's eyes because the testing is the data point that sort of affirms their ability to do well on a college campus.
而且高分成绩通常有助于提升来自代表性不足背景、档案中没有其他强大且令人信服要素的学生的情况，并在委员会眼中提升他们，因为测试是确认他们在大学校园里表现良好的数据点。
He argues that at Yale, they have figured out a way to keep using the SAT, but still increase the diversity of their first year class. In the last eight years, they've gone from 12% low income students to 21% and 12% first generation students to 19%. Right now, at the point of the year that we are in right now, we are coming to the end of the selection process at most top schools around the country. They usually send out decisions to students by the end of March. Yale saw over 11,000 more applicants than last year. Quinlan says they've been working six and seven days a week to get to them all. It's also a more diverse pool of applicants than in the past.
他认为在耶鲁，他们已经找到了一种既能继续使用SAT，又能增加一年级学生多样性的方法。在过去八年中，他们的低收入学生比例从12%上升到21%，第一代大学生比例从12%上升到19%。现在，在我们所处的这一年里，我们正在接近全国大多数顶尖学校选拔过程的终点。他们通常在三月底前向学生发出决定。耶鲁收到的申请比去年多了11000份以上。Quinlan说他们一直在每周工作六到七天来处理所有申请。这也是一个比过去更多样化的申请群体。
But whether or not that will translate to what the overall admissions outcomes are still remains to be seen.
但那是否会转化为最终的招生结果还有待观察。
Do you feel like not having the SAT is actually giving you access to students that you wouldn't have had access to? And you feel like, oh, there's a plus sign to it also.
你觉得没有SAT是否真的让你获得了以前无法获得的学生的入学机会？你觉得它也有一种积极的一面吗？
Yes, but I'll have more to say about that when we get through the process and we can actually see whether or not those students are rising in our pool and getting admitted, and they're ultimately coming to Yale. But I think it is clear that there are students who are in our pool this year who would not have been in our pool previously because of our test optional policies.
是的，但当我们走完整个过程，真正能看到这些学生是否在我们的人才库中上升并被录取，且最终来到耶鲁时，我会说得更多。但我认为很明显，今年我们的库里有一些以前不会有的学生，因为我们的可选考试政策。
I think the big question on a lot of the schools that suddenly went test optional this year was, how hard would this be to do their jobs without the SATs, where they come out of the process confident that they had chosen the best students for their schools? The nonprofit that does the other big standardized test, the ACT test, did a survey of admissions and enrollment directors asking about this. A third of them said going test optional this year made admissions decisions highly or extremely difficult. Of course, that means 2/3 did not see it that way. The admissions directors that I talked to all said, wasn't so bad. If anything, it proved to them that doing admissions without the SATs was manageable, like they could do it and find students they were happy with. Again, Jeremiah Quinlan from Yale.
我认为今年那些突然实行可选考试的学校面临的一个大问题是，在没有SAT的情况下完成工作有多难，他们是否确信自己为学校选择了最好的学生？运营另一个大型标准化测试ACT的非营利组织对招生和入学主任进行了问卷调查。三分之一的人表示，今年实行可选考试使得招生决定非常或极其困难。当然，这意味着三分之二的人并不这么认为。我交谈过的招生主任都说，并没有那么糟糕。如果有的话，这证明了在没有SAT的情况下进行招生是可行的，他们可以做到并找到让他们满意的学生。再次回到耶鲁的Jeremiah Quinlan。
And I can say that it has not been as disruptive as we had thought it was going to be. We have found that if you just spend a little bit more time looking at the transcript, the essays, letters of recommendation, or even an interview, you can find evidence of academic preparation or curiosity or excitement or fit for Yale that can make us confident in our ability to admit the right type of students.
我可以肯定地说，它并没有像我们原先认为的那样具有破坏性。我们发现，如果你只是多花一点时间查看成绩单、论文、推荐信，甚至是面试，你就可以找到学术准备、好奇心、兴奋感或与耶鲁契合度的证据，这让我们能够确信我们有能力录取正确类型的学生。
One thing on applications that became a lot more important to the admissions people I talked to, now that they didn't have the SATs, seeing the rigor of a student's curriculum, like how many advanced placement classes did they take, that kind of thing. And what did they get in those classes? Understandable, of course, but it obviously gave a boost to students from high schools with more resources that offer lots of advanced classes.
在没有SAT的情况下，我对申请材料中变得更加重要的一个方面是，查看学生课程的严谨性，比如他们修了多少高级先修课程之类的。以及他们在这些课程中获得了什么成绩？当然可以理解，但这显然给了来自拥有更多资源、提供大量高级课程的高中的学生一种推动力。
As for what's going to happen after the pandemic, will schools go back to requiring the SAT, several admissions directors that I talked to said that it was going to be hard to go back to the way things were. They thought their schools might have to stay test optional just to compete with all the other schools that will stay test optional. The 900-pound gorilla at the table on that one is the University of California, whose Board of Regents seems very committed to not going back to the SAT. To attract California students who might decide not to take the test or to compete with the University of California for the best students, one admissions director said he might have to stay test optional. Though, on the flip side, Jon Boeckenstedt thinks maybe some elite schools will see advantages in going back to the SAT.
至于疫情之后会发生什么，学校是否会重新要求SAT，我交谈过的几位招生主任表示，很难回到过去的样子。他们认为他们的学校可能必须保持可选考试，只是为了与所有其他也将保持可选考试的学校竞争。这件事的“大象在屋子里”的问题是加州大学，其校董会似乎非常致力于不再回到SAT。为了吸引可能决定不参加考试的加州学生，或者为了与加州大学竞争最好的学生，一位招生主任说他可能不得不保持可选考试。虽然另一方面，Jon Boeckenstedt认为也许一些精英学校会看到重新启用SAT的好处。
So there's reputational benefits to it. You must be really good because you're hard to get into because your test scores suggest that.
所以这有声誉上的好处。你一定很优秀，因为你很难进，因为你的测试分数暗示了这一点。
Also he told Paul some schools like the SATs because they need students who can pay full tuition, and high SAT scores give them the reason to pick those kids over others.
他还告诉Paul，一些学校喜欢SAT是因为他们需要付得起全额学费的学生，而高SAT分数给了他们选择那些孩子而非其他孩子的理由。
And it gives them a justification for it.
而且它给了他们一个理由。
But you're saying it's a justification because it's hard to say that out loud, but it's easy to say we need test scores.
但你是说这是一种理由，因为很难大声说出来，但说我们需要考试分数很容易。
It's easy to say we want test scores. It's hard to say we would prefer to have 60% of our students not receive financial aid.
说我们想要考试分数很容易。说我们宁愿60%的学生不需要经济援助很难。
We invited the nonprofit that runs the SATs, the College Board, for an interview about their future in a post-pandemic world. They declined, but sent a written statement saying the College Board supports schools that decided to go test optional and stating also, quote, "When used in context, test scores can help admissions officers diversify campus and set students up for success when they arrive." It's clear, however this shakes out, the SATs and ACTs are going to emerge from the pandemic substantially weaker than they were before, like football teams that lost tons of yardage that they may or may not regain.
我们邀请了运营SAT的非营利组织“大学理事会”进行关于他们在后疫情世界中的未来的采访。他们拒绝了，但发了一份书面声明称，大学理事会支持决定实行可选考试的学校，并声明称，“在语境中使用时，测试分数可以帮助招生官员实现校园多样化，并帮助学生在到达校园时取得成功。”然而，无论结果如何，SAT和ACT注定将从疫情中走出来，表现得比以前明显疲软，就像那些损失了大量码数、可能恢复也可能无法恢复的橄榄球队一样。
In that survey of colleges that the SAT's competitor, the ACT test, published this month, half the schools that went test optional because of COVID said that they would be unlikely to go back to requiring SAT or ACT scores. In the end, the main thing that will probably determine whether schools go back to requiring the SAT will be how the students perform, who they chose without SATs. Will more of them drop out? Will their grades be lower?
在那份ACT本月发布的关于大学的调查中，一半因COVID实行可选考试的学校表示，他们不太可能回到要求SAT或ACT分数的道路上。最终，决定学校是否回到要求SAT的因素可能主要取决于那些没有SAT就被录取的学生表现如何。他们的辍学率会更高吗？他们的成绩会更低吗？
One of the things I learned when I was calling around to admissions directors is that whatever the studies say about how good grades are at predicting who's going to do well in college, lots of them still trust the SATs and find them useful. One told me he definitely was worried that the students he was choosing without the SATs would not succeed at his school. And in their jobs, admissions directors are evaluated on whether the students they select stay in school and graduate.
我在致电招生主任时学到的事情之一是，无论研究对于成绩在预测谁在大学表现良好方面有多优秀有什么评价，他们中许多人仍然信任SAT并发现它很有用。其中一位告诉我，他确实担心他没有SAT选择的学生不会在他的学校取得成功。而且在他们的工作中，招生主任的表现评估取决于他们选择的学生是否留在学校并毕业。
Coming up, a glimpse at a very different way to run a college. And as part of it, letting in tons of students without looking at their SATs, that's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
接下来，看看运营大学的一种非常不同的方式。作为其中一部分，在不查看SAT的情况下录取大量学生，那将在来自芝加哥公共广播电台的节目继续中揭晓，节目一分钟后回来。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's show, The Campus Tour Has Been Cancelled. With college admissions all jumbled up this year, thanks to the pandemic, we're doing an episode today about one of the biggest changes that's come as part of it. Most schools around the country, including most of the top schools-- for now anyway-- have stopped requiring the SAT and ACT tests in admissions.
这里是《This American Life》。我是Ira Glass。今天的节目，“校园巡回展已取消”。由于疫情导致今年的大学招生乱成一团，我们今天制作了一期关于随之而来的最大变化之一的节目。全国大多数学校，包括大多数顶尖学校——目前为止 anyway——已经停止在招生中要求SAT和ACT考试。
I co-reported today's program with reporter Paul Tough. So far in our program, we've been talking about why this is such a big deal, what its impact might be. And in this last part of the show, we're going to turn to the future, or anyway, a picture of one possible future. We've arrived at Act Two of our program. Act Two, A World Without the Need for Number Two Pencils.
我和记者Paul Tough共同报道了今天的节目。到目前为止，我们一直在讨论为什么这是一件大事，它的影响可能是什么。在节目的最后一部分，我们将转向未来，或者至少是描绘一种可能的未来。我们来到了节目的第二幕。第二幕，一个不需要2号铅笔的世界。
So if you want to imagine what college admissions might look like without the SAT being required, one place you could go is the University of Texas at Austin. UT Austin is the flagship school of the Texas system, one of the top ranked public universities in the country. And since 1998, because of a state law, they've been doing something at UT that no other big university in the country does.
所以如果你想想象没有SAT要求时的大学招生是什么样子，你可以去的地方之一是德克萨斯大学奥斯汀分校（UT Austin）。UT奥斯汀是德州体系的旗舰学校，是全国排名前列的公立大学之一。从1998年开始，由于一项州法律，他们一直在UT做着全国其他任何大型大学都没有做过的事情。
Every year, they admit most of their freshman class based strictly on student's class rank-- who has the highest grades in their high school-- without paying attention to their SAT scores at all. This law is known as the Top 10% Rule because the way it worked when they started was that if you were in the top 10% of your high school class, you were automatically admitted to UT Austin. Since then, the percentage of students has gone down. Now it is the top 6% of your class, but it works the same. It doesn't matter what you get in your SAT. If you're in the top of your class, you're in.
每年，他们录取的大部分一年级学生严格基于学生的班级排名——即谁在高中成绩最高——根本不考虑他们的SAT分数。这条法律被称为“前10%规则”，因为他们开始时运行的方式是，如果你在高中班级的前10%，你就会被UT奥斯汀自动录取。从那时起，学生的百分比下降了。现在是你班级的前6%，但其原理是一样的。你SAT考多少分并不重要。如果你在班级前列，你就进去了。
So what you end up with is the top students from rich suburban high schools around Dallas and rural towns in West Texas and Latino majority schools in the Rio Grande Valley. And it makes for a very different freshman class at UT than you would see at most state flagship colleges. And it also makes it an especially interesting place to ask a question that's relevant now as we contemplate whether to bring back the SAT after the pandemic. What happens if you just ignore students' test scores? What happens if you admit students with great grades from a variety of high schools who do well in the classroom, but not on the SAT? Students like Daniela.
所以你最终得到的是来自达拉斯周边富裕郊区高中、西德州农村城镇和格兰德河谷以拉丁裔为主的高中的顶尖学生。这使得UT的新生班级与你在大多数州旗舰学院看到的情况大不相同。这也使得它成为一个特别有趣的地方，来问一个当我们考虑疫情后是否恢复SAT时相关的问题。如果你仅仅忽视学生的测试分数会发生什么？如果你录取来自不同高中、在课堂上表现出色但在SAT上表现一般的优秀成绩学生会发生什么？像Daniela这样的学生。
Well, it turns out admitting students based only on their grades, their class rank from high schools all over the state, makes UT a very different university from others in some significant and interesting ways. Paul explains.
好吧，事实证明，仅仅基于他们的成绩，也就是来自全州各地高中的班级排名来录取学生，使得UT在某些重要且有趣的方式上成为一所与其他大学非常不同的大学。Paul来解释。
When I was reporting my book, I spent a lot of time at UT, and I met a lot of students there who'd been admitted with excellent high school grades and lower test scores. Ivonne I met on the first day of her freshman calculus class. She was from the west side of San Antonio, a neighborhood where no one had much money, a high school where teachers kept leaving in the middle of the year. In many ways, her story was just like Daniela's. She was number two in her class, but her SAT score was only so-so. In her case, though, her test score didn't make her question her identity and her self-worth, like it did for Daniela. She just figured it was her high school.
当我在报道我的书时，我在UT花了很多时间，我在那里遇到了很多学生，他们以优异的高中成绩和较低的测试分数被录取。我在Ivonne大一微积分课的第一天遇到了她。她来自圣安东尼奥西区，一个没人有多少钱的社区，一所老师在年中不断离开的高中。在许多方面，她的故事就像Daniela一样。她在班里排名第二，但她的SAT分数只是平平。不过，对她而言，测试分数并没有像对Daniela那样让她质疑自己的身份和自我价值。她只是认为这是她高中的问题。
I realized that it's a reflection of my educational system, the one that I come from, so for my high school. And I think a lot of us, we knew. We talked about our school and how it was really bad. And this is our reality. This is kind of what we have to deal with, how we knew our education was terrible.
我意识到这是我的教育体系的一个反映，我所来自的体系，也就是我的高中。我想我们很多人都知道。我们谈论我们的学校以及它是多么糟糕。这就是我们的现实。这就是我们必须处理的事情，我们如何知道我们的教育是多么糟糕。
After she saw her SAT score, Ivonne didn't apply to a lot of her first choice schools, just like Daniela. But unlike Daniela, Ivonne knew she had this safety net. The SAT was not going to derail her college plans.
在看到她的SAT分数后，Ivonne并没有像Daniela那样申请很多她的首选学校。但与Daniela不同，Ivonne知道她有这个安全网。SAT不会阻碍她的大学计划。
It was like, no matter the consequences of this exam, I know UT is going to take me because my ranking is good. So it's fine. I still have UT. I'll go to UT.
就像是，无论考试后果如何，我知道UT会录取我，因为我的排名很好。所以没关系。我仍然有UT。我会去UT。
And she didn't see UT as a consolation prize. She knew it was a great school. Her older sister was going there. It seemed exciting. But arriving at UT was a shock to our system, especially Calculus. Her professor was a man named Uri Treisman, a well-known math educator. And his strategy is to start the first class of freshman calculus with these really high level mathematical proofs. So everyone can feel confused together, like a bonding exercise. It freaked Ivonne out. She was a math major, and she'd taken AP Calculus, but she says her math teachers in high school didn't really seemed to know what they were doing. And when I met her that first day of freshman calculus, she was totally lost.
她并没有把UT视为安慰奖。她知道这是一所好学校。她的姐姐就在那里上学。这似乎令人兴奋。但到达UT对我们的体系来说是一个冲击，尤其是微积分。她的教授是一个名叫Uri Treisman的人，一位著名的数学教育家。他的策略是用这些非常高水平的数学证明来开始大一微积分的第一课。这样每个人都可以感到困惑，就像一种结合练习。这让Ivonne感到惊慌。她是数学专业的，修过AP微积分，但她说她高中的数学老师似乎并不真正知道他们在做什么。当我大一微积分的第一天见到她时，她完全迷失了。
Because I'd never seen proofs, I'd never seen calculus taught in that way. So I would fail almost every exam and just struggle every time it was-- calculus made me doubt my ability to complete college so many times.
因为我从来没见过证明，我从来没见过用那种方式教授微积分。所以我几乎所有的考试都挂科，而且每次都在挣扎——微积分让我无数次怀疑我完成大学学业的能力。
When the Top 10% Rule was introduced in Texas in the late '90s, this was what people were worried about. Good students from subpar high schools would be out of their depth at a rigorous place like UT Austin-- basically, the same worry that a lot of admissions officers today are having, now that they're admitting students without SAT scores. They fear students will be like Ivonne was when she first got to UT.
当90年代末德州引入“前10%规则”时，这就是人们担心的事情。来自不佳高中的优秀学生会在像UT奥斯汀这样严苛的地方感到力不从心——基本上，这和今天许多招生官员现在的担忧是一样的，因为他们现在正在录取没有SAT分数的学生。他们担心学生会像Ivonne刚到UT时那样。
And there's some data to justify those fears. Students like Ivonne, students where there's a real mismatch between their good high school grades and their lower SATs, they usually do quite well when they get to good colleges. But their graduation rates are, on average, slightly lower than students with higher SATs. And for some of them, the transition to college can be rough. Ivonne says for her, the problem was that she never learned in high school how to study.
而且有一些数据可以证明这些担忧是合理的。像Ivonne这样的学生，在他们好的高中成绩和较低的SAT之间存在真正不匹配的学生，当他们进入好大学时，通常表现相当不错。但他们的毕业率平均比SAT成绩较高的学生略低。对于他们中的一些人来说，向大学的过渡可能会很艰难。Ivonne说，对她而言，问题在于她从未在高中学会如何学习。
Because I never had to study for high school, and high school was never challenging academically.
因为我从来不需要为了高中而学习，高中在学术上也从不具有挑战性。
So when you first got there, did you feel like there was sort of-- I don't know-- two tiers of students, like the ones who were coming from backgrounds like yours, where their high schools weren't the greatest, and others who had had sort of perfect academic preparation?
所以当你刚到那里时，你是否觉得好像有……我不知道……两个阶层的学生，那种来自像你这样背景、高中不是最好的学生，还有其他人拥有某种完美的学术准备？
I think you could kind of just tell by what some people were wearing.
我想你从某些人穿什么就能看出来。
By the way, this interview was over the internet. And the sound quality wasn't the best.
顺便说一下，这次采访是通过互联网进行的。音质不是最好的。
So some girls, they would wear Uggs. I obviously knew I couldn't afford Uggs. And then that's when I would start asking them questions like, oh, what high school did you go? So I would bring up the past to see-- I guess, in a sense, make myself understand it's OK. It's like, I'm struggling now because I come from a bad high school, and they are doing better because they were from a better high school.
所以有些女孩，她们会穿Uggs。我显然知道我负担不起Uggs。然后那时候我就会开始问她们问题，哦，你上哪所高中？所以我会提起过去看看——我想在某种意义上，让我自己明白没关系。就像，我现在挣扎是因为我来自一所糟糕的高中，而她们表现更好是因为她们来自更好的高中。
This was exactly the situation that her calculus professor, Uri Treisman, was focused on-- students who feel like they're starting from way behind. Here's one of the things he would do. Every weekend, he would have these long office hours where these students would come in and talk. I sat in on a lot of these sessions back in 2017. And they weren't anything like other professor's office hours. He and his students didn't really talk much about math.
这正是她的微积分教授Uri Treisman所关注的情况——那些觉得他们从远远落后位置开始的学生。这是他会做的事情之一。每个周末，他都会有很长的办公时间，让这些学生进来谈话。我在2017年旁听了很多次这样的会议。它们一点也不像其他教授的办公时间。他和他的学生并不真正谈论数学。
Hi, good morning.
嗨，早上好。
Ivonne.
Ivonne。
Yeah.
是的。
You are working so hard in this class.
你在课上工作得太辛苦了。
Yeah.
是的。
I mean, are you getting any sleep?
我的意思是，你有在睡觉吗？
I feel like sometimes it's more than most, but not the best.
我觉得有时比大多数人多，但不是最好的。
This was October. Ivonne was about halfway through freshman calculus. She was still feeling totally out of her depth. And at a lot of colleges, what they do with students like that is put them in a remedial class, something they can handle. Treisman does the opposite. It's a method he came up with decades ago when he was teaching at Berkeley. He noticed that when struggling students were put into remedial math, they usually never caught up.
那是十月。Ivonne大约完成了一半的大一微积分。她仍然感到完全力不从心。在许多大学，他们对待像那样的学生的方式是把他们放进补习班，他们能应付的东西。Treisman做了相反的事情。这是他在几十年前在伯克利任教时想出的一种方法。他注意到，当挣扎的学生被放入补习数学时，他们通常永远追不上。
But if you took the same students and put them in a challenging program, pushed them to see how well they could perform, they would rise to the occasion. First, though, there was usually a lot of anguish. And at UT, freshman calculus was in large part about managing students' anxiety and self-doubt. So Treisman's office hours were a combination of bonding session, therapy, and pep talk.
但如果你把相同的学生放入一个具有挑战性的项目中，推动他们看看他们能表现多好，他们就会挺身而出。不过，起初通常会有很多痛苦。在UT，大一微积分很大程度上是关于管理学生的焦虑和自我怀疑。所以Treisman的办公时间是结合练习、治疗和打气谈话。
You're going to be successful in here. You ended up in a really honors calculus, super duper difficult.
你会成功的。你最终进入了一个非常荣誉的微积分课程，非常非常难。
Yeah.
是的。
And most people would run away. You are feeling tremendously stressed, but you're not running away.
大多数人会逃跑。你感到非常紧张，但你没有逃跑。
I still love math, even though I feel like I'm struggling with it. I remember my teacher once said, I'm very stubborn. So I feel like I still want to stay in something that I--
我仍然喜欢数学，尽管我觉得我在挣扎。我记得我的老师曾经说，我非常固执。所以我感觉我仍然想留在一些我……
Now this is a key characteristic of mathematicians-- stubbornness. We don't give up. But I'm worried that I'm pushing you in a way where you are losing self-confidence.
现在这是数学家的一个关键特征——固执。我们不放弃。但我担心我正在以一种让你失去自信的方式推动你。
Oh, I feel like I definitely am.
哦，我觉得我绝对是。
Treisman tells her he knows she's in a class with students who already mastered this material back in high school.
Treisman告诉她，他知道她在一个班里，班里的学生早在高中就掌握了这些材料。
You are going to catch up with them in a few weeks, in a month. But because you always did well and now you're struggling, you're saying to yourself, maybe I'm not good enough to be here. Is that what's in your head?
你在几周内，在一个月内，你就会赶上他们。但因为你总是表现好，现在你在挣扎，你对自己说，也许我不够好，不能留在这里。是你脑子里的那个想法吗？
It pops up once in a while that I feel like-- I don't know-- it is stressful. Because I feel like I'm falling behind because I'm not getting the full concept. But I know if I put my effort, I eventually will. But I feel like by that time, it would be too late if that makes sense.
它偶尔会冒出来，让我觉得——我不知道——这很有压力。因为我觉得我在落后，因为我没有掌握完整概念。但我知道如果我付出努力，我最终会掌握的。但我感觉到了那个时候，就太晚了，如果这有意义的话。
It won't be too late. You have to trust me.
不会太晚的。你必须相信我。
Ivonne wanted to trust Professor Treisman, but she didn't feel like she was catching up, not at all. On the first big test, Ivonne got a 67. On the first midterm, she did worse, a 59. With the second midterm coming up in the middle of November, Ivonne was studying like crazy. And the night before the exam there was a moment when the puzzle pieces briefly seemed to be fitting into place. I talked to her later that week.
Ivonne想相信Treisman教授，但她觉得自己根本没有赶上，一点也没有。在第一次大考中，Ivonne得了67分。在第一次期中考试中，她做得更糟，59分。随着第二次期中考试在11月中旬到来，Ivonne疯狂地学习。在考试前一晚，有一个瞬间，拼图块似乎短暂地拼凑在了一起。我那周晚些时候和她谈过。
I sat down, and I was like, OK, I can see the logic, and I can do it. And then sometime later on that night, I couldn't do it anymore. The problems that I did before became harder. I could--
我坐下来，心想，好的，我能看到逻辑，我可以做。然后那天晚上的某个时候，我就做不到了。我之前做过的问题变得更难了。我可以——
Oh, you looked back at what you used to know, and suddenly you were going backwards.
哦，你回顾了你过去知道的东西，突然间你是在倒退。
Yeah, I felt like I was moving backwards.
是的，我觉得我在倒退。
It's like a horror movie.
这就像一部恐怖电影。
And then I was like, OK, don't do this to yourself, so I went to sleep. I slept it off. But then I woke up and I woke up feeling like it was gone. I think it was the stress probably. That's why I started crying on the bus.
然后我想，好的，不要这样对待自己，所以我去睡觉了。我睡了一觉。但当我醒来时，我感觉它消失了。我想可能是压力。那就是为什么我在公共汽车上开始哭泣。
Crying on the what?
在什么上哭？
On the bus. I was coming over here, and I'm like, I don't feel ready. I really can't take it.
在公共汽车上。我正过来这里，心想，我不觉得自己准备好了。我真的受不了了。
She got off the bus, and she was walking through campus on her way to the midterm and her phone rang. It was her mom back home in San Antonio.
她下了车，在去参加期中考试的校园里走着，她的电话响了。是她在圣安东尼奥家里的妈妈。
And she was like, have you been crying? Why does it sound like you're crying? And then I told her, I don't feel prepared. And she's like, oh, it's OK. You can come back to UTSA.
她说，你一直在哭吗？为什么听起来像你在哭？然后我告诉她，我不觉得准备好了。她说，哦，没关系。你可以回到UTSA。
UTSA is the University of Texas in San Antonio, less demanding than UT Austin and less prestigious.
UTSA是圣安东尼奥德克萨斯大学，比UT奥斯汀要求低，名气也小。
So I guess that made it worse. I actually hung up on her.
所以我猜那让情况更糟了。我实际上挂断了她的电话。
Ivonne sat down on a bench outside of the lecture hall where the exam was going to happen, looking miserable. The teaching assistant, a woman named Erica Winterer, came over to check on her. The two of them talked it over, and Erica told her she should just take the exam later in the week.
Ivonne坐在讲堂外面的一条长椅上，考试就要在那里举行，她看起来很痛苦。助教，一个名叫Erica Winterer的女人，过来查看她的情况。他们俩谈了谈，Erica告诉她，她应该在当天晚些时候参加考试。
I guess because I looked like I was crying, and I looked hysterical. And so Professor Treisman emailed me that day. He's like, I know, I heard what happened. And honestly, I didn't reply because I feel ashamed. Because I feel like they're putting in all this effort, and I feel like I'm just not meeting up to them, if that makes sense. So I guess, I don't only feel like I'm failing myself. I feel like I'm failing them.
我猜因为我看起来像在哭，而且看起来很歇斯底里。所以Treisman教授那天给我发了邮件。他说，我知道，我听说了发生了什么。老实说，我没有回复，因为我感到羞耻。因为我觉得他们投入了所有这些努力，而我感觉我根本没有达到他们的要求，如果这有意义的话。所以我猜，我不仅觉得我辜负了自己。我觉得我辜负了他们。
She got a 55 on that midterm. Things seemed to be heading in the wrong direction, and the final was coming up. In Professor Treisman's calculus classes, there was always a lot of pressure before the final, because if you did well, that grade would replace all of your previous grades in the course. But if Ivonne wasn't able to turn things around in the final, she'd end up with a D or an F in the course. She'd probably have to switch majors.
那次期中考试她得了55分。事情似乎正在向错误的方向发展，期末考试就要到了。在Treisman教授的微积分课上，期末考试前总是有很大的压力，因为如果你表现好，那个成绩会取代你课程中所有之前的成绩。但如果Ivonne不能在期末考试中扭转局面，她最终会在课程中拿到D或F。她可能不得不换专业。
One of the things that makes the University of Texas interesting is that the kind of support Ivonne was getting from Erica and Professor Treisman was happening in different forms all over campus. The person coordinating this was a science professor named David Laude. He had started small, trying to help students who were failing his own introductory chemistry course, who often had significantly lower SAT scores. He created a special section for them with smaller classes, extra attention, kind of a school within a school on a sprawling campus of 40,000 students. Just like Uri Treisman, he emphasized that this was not a remedial program. These students took the same exams as everybody else, covered the same challenging material.
让德克萨斯大学变得有趣的事情之一是，Ivonne从Erica和Treisman教授那里得到的支持形式在校园各处都在以不同形式发生。协调这件事的人是一位名叫David Laude的科学教授。他起步很小，试图帮助那些在他的化学入门课上不及格的学生，他们往往有显著较低的SAT分数。他为他们创建了一个特殊部分，有更小的班级，额外的关注，某种程度上是在拥有40000名学生的庞大校园里，学校里的一所学校。就像Uri Treisman一样，他强调这不是一个补习项目。这些学生参加与其他人相同的考试，涵盖相同的挑战性材料。
And in the end, those students, even though, just looking at SAT distributions, were several hundred points lower on average, ended up getting exactly the same grades as the students in the larger course.
最终，那些学生，即使仅仅看着SAT分布，平均低了几百分，最终获得的成绩与大班课程中的学生完全相同。
And I'm curious about at that moment, what you thought about those SAT scores. I feel like there are a lot of science professors out there who look at a group that has lower SAT scores and just thinks, these kids are not as smart, right? That's measuring something real about them. Did you have that feeling? What did you make of those low SAT scores?
而且我对那一刻感到好奇，你是怎么看待那些SAT分数的。我觉得外面有很多科学教授，看着一个SAT分数较低的群体，只会认为这些孩子不如别人聪明，对吧？那是在衡量关于他们的某种真实的东西。你有过那种感觉吗？你是怎么看待那些低SAT分数的？
Well, as someone who earned one of those low SAT scores myself, it wasn't as if I was-- I think it's safe to say that my view of SAT scores and what they meant about an individual was probably different from a lot of folks.
好吧，作为一个自己也拿过那些低SAT分数的人，这并不是说我是——我认为可以肯定地说，我对SAT分数以及它们对个人的意义的看法可能与很多人不同。
He grew up in a farm town, and when he got to college, he had no idea what he was doing. He almost dropped out his first year. So he could relate. And in 2012, when he became a vice provost at UT, he took what he learned from helping his chemistry students, expanded it, and brought it to the entire campus-- peer mentors, study groups, counseling, summer orientations, tutoring centers. He called it the kitchen sink approach.
他在农场城镇长大，当他进入大学时，他根本不知道自己在做什么。他第一年几乎退学了。所以他能感同身受。2012年，当他成为UT的副教务长时，他采用了从帮助化学学生身上学到的东西，扩大了它，并把它带到了整个校园——同行导师、学习小组、咨询、暑期入职指导、补习中心。他称之为“厨房水槽方法”。
And how much time it took was very different than what you might think. I don't think these students should be in a four-year program that isolates them from the rest of the campus. My sense was give them a semester, maybe two, and then mainstream them so that by the time they're a sophomore in college, they really don't appear to be different from anybody else.
而且它花费的时间与你可能想象的非常不同。我不认为这些学生应该在一个将他们与校园其他部分隔离开的四年制项目中。我的感觉是给他们一个学期，也许两个，然后把他们主流化，这样当他们成为大学二年级学生时，他们看起来真的与任何人没有什么不同。
Ivonne was placed into a couple of Laude's support programs when she enrolled at UT. And in calculus after her midterm breakdown, Erica, her TA, invited her to join an all-female study group she had set up. They started meeting a couple of times a week in the library.
Ivonne在入学UT时被安排进了Laude的几个支持项目中。在期中崩溃后的微积分课上，她的助教Erica邀请她参加一个她设立的全女性学习小组。他们开始每周在图书馆碰面几次。
OK, but I want to answer Ivonne's question. Is U, right here in this integral, is U a constant or not?
好的，但我想要回答Ivonne的问题。在积分里这里的U，右边这里的U，是一个常数吗？
That's Erica. In these early sessions, they could spend an hour and a half on a single problem. There were a lot of long silences.
那是Erica。在这些早期的会议中，他们可以在一个问题上花费一个半小时。有很多长时间的沉默。
Why?
为什么？
No one wanted to be the first person to suggest a wrong answer.
没有人想成为第一个建议错误答案的人。
You're just going to have to write things down that are wrong. You're going to be wrong in college so much more than you were in high school, and it's super annoying.
你将不得不写下错误的东西。你在大学里犯错的次数会比你在高中时多得多，这超级烦人。
But then in one session, the light bulb went on, and Ivonne was the first one to get it.
但随后在一次会议中，灯泡亮了，Ivonne是第一个领悟到的人。
Is that related to getting 2 over here? What did we start with?
那是与得到2有关吗？我们在哪里开始的？
Wait, yeah. Because you plug in I, and then you move the I over. And then you divide it by 2, and then you get the 2 in front.
等等，是的。因为你代入I，然后你移走I。然后你除以2，然后你在前面得到2。
OK.
好的。
[INAUDIBLE]
[听不清]
It was one of the first times she made a suggestion in calculus all year. As the study group continued, Ivonne started taking more chances, risking more wrong answers, growing more confident. And things started to click just in time. I saw her on the morning of the calculus final, and she looked happy. She told me she had gone back through the whole textbook over the weekend. And for the first time, she understood everything.
那是她全年第一次在微积分课上提出建议。随着学习小组继续，Ivonne开始抓住更多机会，冒更多错误答案的风险，变得越来越自信。事情开始就在及时的时候点击了。我在微积分期末考试那天早上见到她，她看起来很开心。她告诉我她周末已经把整本教科书看了一遍。而且第一次，她理解了一切。
I was like, wait, hold on, this makes sense. And I was like, OK, this relates to that and this to that. So now I was able to relate later chapters to earlier chapters. Like, oh, it makes sense why we learned that in the beginning.
我心想，等等，等等，这说得通。然后我想，好的，这与那个有关，这与那个有关。所以现在我能够把后面的章节与前面的章节联系起来。就像，哦，难怪我们在开始时学习那个。
That's so great.
那太棒了。
Yeah.
是的。
She was right to be excited. She aced the final, which meant she had an A in the course. She went on to advanced calculus the next semester and did well in that, too. She went from failure and despair in October of her freshman year to being a successful math major by the end of May.
她是正确的，她很兴奋。她期末考试拿了A，这意味着她在课程中拿到了A。下学期她上了高等微积分并且在那门课上也做得很好。她从大一十月的失败和绝望中走出来，到了五月底成为了一名成功的数学专业学生。
Remember David Laude's point that struggling freshmen don't need constant support over all four years of college, just a semester or two? That's what happened with Ivonne. Once things clicked for her in that calculus class, they never really unclicked. She says once her courses got harder in junior and senior year, it didn't feel like classmates from better schools had an edge anymore. It was equally hard for everybody. She was contributing as much in study groups as anyone.
记住David Laude的观点，挣扎的一年级学生不需要在大学四年里一直得到支持，只需要一个学期或两个？这就是Ivonne发生的事情。一旦她在微积分课上理解了事情，它们就从未真正解开。她说一旦她的课程在三四年级变得更难，来自更好学校的同学似乎不再有优势了。对每个人来说都同样困难。她在学习小组中的贡献和任何人一样多。
Ivonne's story is actually not that unusual. There's an economist at Columbia University named Sandra Black, who has looked at the effect of the top 10% program at UT, not just on individual students, but on everybody. She did this one study where she looked at students like Ivonne, students who got into UT only because of top 10.
Ivonne的故事实际上并不那么不寻常。哥伦比亚大学有一位经济学家名叫Sandra Black，她研究了UT前10%项目的影响，不仅对个人学生，而且对每个人。她做了这项研究，她观察了像Ivonne这样的学生，那些仅仅因为前10%才进入UT的学生。
So this is the really interesting part, I think, or the really cool finding is that they do really well. So, more likely to graduate with a four-year degree. They do better in terms of earnings in the long run. And so, really, it seems like this concern, I think, that people have that these students are going to be unprepared really seems not to be an issue. They aren't out of their league.
所以这是非常有趣的部分，我认为，或者是非常酷的发现，是他们做得真的很好。所以，毕业获得四年制学位的可能性更高。从长远来看，他们在收入方面做得更好。所以，真的，这似乎是人们担心的那些学生将未受准备真的似乎不是一个问题。他们并没有力不从心。
The remarkable thing about this data is that it's all from the first years of top 10%, back before David Laude introduced his programs to the campus. These students are doing even better now. Sandra Black also did a study imagining how UT Austin and Texas A&M, the other state flagship, would change if they suddenly introduced a strict SAT cutoff to top 10%, rejecting students whose scores fell below a certain point. She found that UT and A&M would have more kids graduating in four years, but only a few percent more. But there'd be a big effect on diversity. Black and Hispanic students would go from 24% of the student body to 14%, and you'd lose 3/4 of the students who came from the lowest income schools.
关于这些数据，显著的事情是它们全部来自前10%的最初几年，回到David Laude向校园引入他的项目之前。这些学生现在表现得更好了。Sandra Black还做了一项研究，想象如果UT奥斯汀和德克萨斯农工大学（另一个州旗舰）突然在前10%中引入严格的SAT截止分数，拒绝那些分数低于一定点的学生，学校会有什么变化。她发现UT和农工会有更多的孩子在四年内毕业，但只多出几个百分点。但多样性会有巨大影响。黑人和西班牙裔学生在学生群体中的比例将从24%下降到14%，你将失去四分之三来自收入最低高中的学生。
So, the cost would be very high relative to the benefit.
所以，相对收益而言，成本将非常高。
Ivonne is now a senior at UT. She's planning to go to graduate school next year in data science. A few weeks ago, she got into Harvard. I have to admit, I don't think it's what I would have predicted for her during those dark days in freshman calculus.
Ivonne现在是UT的大四学生。她计划明年去读数据科学的研究生。几周前，她被哈佛录取了。我必须承认，我不认为这是我在她大一微积分那段黑暗时期为她预测的结果。
Do you ever think about what would have happened if there was not a top 10% program where you would have gone, where you would have gotten in, how your life would be different?
你有没有想过如果没有前10%项目你会去哪里，你会进入哪里，你的生活会有什么不同？
Honestly, I think that's a really good question because I think my life would be very different because I think if top 10 was not a rule, I would have probably not applied to UT, not applied to universities. I would have probably stayed home and applied to a community college.
老实说，我认为那是一个非常好的问题，因为我认为我的生活会有很大不同，因为我认为如果前10%不是规则，我可能根本不会申请UT，不会申请大学。我可能会待在家里申请社区学院。
If you look back to the moment right before Ivonne was admitted to the University of Texas, you can see the paths diverging in front of her. One would have led her to community college in San Antonio. The other led her to graduate school at Harvard. Right now, in admissions offices all over the country, they're finalizing their decisions. And for the first time, at hundreds of schools, the SAT won't be there to stop them from enrolling students like Ivonne, which means that next year, maybe, at least a few more students would get the chance to prove themselves the way she did.
如果你回顾Ivonne被德克萨斯大学录取前的那一刻，你可以看到路径在她面前分叉。一条会把她引向圣安东尼奥的社区学院。另一条引向哈佛的研究生院。现在，在全国各地的招生办公室里，他们正在敲定他们的决定。而且第一次，在数百所学校里，SAT将不会在那里阻止他们录取像Ivonne这样的学生，这意味着明年，也许，至少有更多的学生将有机会以她那样的方式证明自己。
Paul Tough, his book about the college admissions process, I cannot say enough about how much I liked it-- the stories of the people that he tells, but also the way that he lays out the data describing the big picture. It's called The Inequality Machine, How College Divides Us.
Paul Tough，关于大学招生过程的书，我怎么夸它都不为过——他讲述的人们的故事，但也包括他铺陈的数据描述的大局。它叫《不平等机器，大学如何分裂我们》。
[MUSIC - "POMP AND CIRCUMSTANCE" BY EDWARD ELGAR, AMADEO LOPEZ]
[音乐 - Edward Elgar创作，Amadeo Lopez演奏的“威风堂堂进行曲”]
Our program was produced today by me and Elna Baker. The people who put together our show today could Ben Calhoun, Dana Chivvis, Sean Cole, Aviva DeKornfeld, Hilary Elkins, Damien Graef, Seth Lind, Tobin Low, Miki Meek, Lina Misitzis, Stowe Nelson, Katherine Rae Mondo, Nadia Reiman, Ari Saperstein, Robyn Semien, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, and Julie Whitaker. Our managing editor is Sarah Abdurrahman. Our senior editor is David Kestenbaum. Our executive editor is Emanuele Berry.
我们的节目今天由我和Elna Baker制作。今天一起把节目组合在一起的人是Ben Calhoun, Dana Chivvis, Sean Cole, Aviva DeKornfeld, Hilary Elkins, Damien Graef, Seth Lind, Tobin Low, Miki Meek, Lina Misitzis, Stowe Nelson, Katherine Rae Mondo, Nadia Reiman, Ari Saperstein, Robyn Semien, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney 和 Julie Whitaker。我们的执行编辑是Sarah Abdurrahman。我们的高级编辑是David Kestenbaum。我们的执行主编是Emanuele Berry。
Special thanks today to Nicole Hurd and the many College Advising Corps counselors and counselees who talked to us, Miranda Suarez from KERA who helped with the reporting, Steven Farmer, Ryan Hogan, Jared Cash, Kat Kouot, Tara Miller, Akil Bello, Kirk Brennan, Robert Schwartz, Christine Isborn, Amira Ringgold, Noor Gill, Kandace Lupercio, Janet Romero, Zach Bleemer, Matt Barnum, Regina Trevino, Eloy Oakley, Susan Pierson-Brown, Kelly Anderson, and Julie Snyder.
今天特别感谢Nicole Hurd以及与我们交谈的许多大学咨询团的辅导员和被咨询者，来自KERA帮助报道的Miranda Suarez, Steven Farmer, Ryan Hogan, Jared Cash, Kat Kouot, Tara Miller, Akil Bello, Kirk Brennan, Robert Schwartz, Christine Isborn, Amira Ringgold, Noor Gill, Kandace Lupercio, Janet Romero, Zach Bleemer, Matt Barnum, Regina Trevino, Eloy Oakley, Susan Pierson-Brown, Kelly Anderson 和 Julie Snyder。
Our website, thisamericanlife.org, where you can listen to our archive of 700 episodes for absolutely free. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our program's confounder, Mr. Torey Malatia. He took one of those BuzzFeed quizzes, Which Character From Sex and the City Are You? It said he was Miranda, even though, of course, he always thought of himself as a Carrie.
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org，在那里你可以完全免费收听我们700集节目的存档。《This American Life》由公共广播交流平台PRX传送到公共广播电台。像往常一样，感谢我们节目的联合创始人Torey Malatia先生。他参加了那些BuzzFeed测验之一，你是《欲望都市》里的哪个角色？结果显示他是Miranda，尽管当然，他总是认为自己是Carrie。
But that test was saying otherwise, you know? So when I got that test result, I was kind of questioning whether I was.
但那个测试却说情况并非如此，你知道吗？所以当我拿到那个测试结果时，我开始怀疑自己是否真的聪明。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是Ira Glass。下周带着更多《This American Life》的故事回来。
[MUSIC - "UNIVERSITY" BY THE WOOLEN MEN]
[音乐 - The Woolen Men创作的“大学”]